there are hundreds of billions of alien
worlds in the Milky Way galaxy
and scientists have already discovered
and confirmed over 5 000 of them
they call these worlds exoplanets some
of them are really small like Kepler 37b
this tiny planet is even smaller than
Mercury the smallest planet in our solar
system Kepler 37 is just slightly larger
than our own Moon it could easily
replace our Cosmic companion in the
night sky only it's pretty far from us
this tiny space rock is located 208
light years from Earth where it orbits a
star that's a bit smaller and cooler
than our sun
small rocky worlds like Kepler 37b are a
pretty rare find because they're so tiny
they're more difficult to spot but
scientists have still managed to confirm
about 200 of these worlds
most of them are many many times closer
to their Stars than our planet is to the
Sun and
kepler-62c is no exception
this mars-sized exoplanet orbits its
star roughly four times closer than
Mercury orbits our sun
it only takes a little over 12 Earth
days to make a full orbit
Kepler's 62c must be scorching hot and
extremely volcanic
definitely not the kind of place you'd
want to visit
and neither is this exoplanet koi 55b
scientists think this planet used to be
the size of Jupiter but then its Sun
exploded into a red giant and swallowed
the planet whole
ah no surprise there koi 55b is
incredibly close to its star
so close that it takes this hellish
World less than five hours to make one
orbit and koi 55b is evaporating so much
that it will soon disappear from its
planetary system
it's not alone
many of these planets have their
atmospheres torn Away by their host
Stars
some 41 light years from Earth there's a
super Earth that used to be a mini
Neptune
GJ 1132b might have had a thick hydrogen
atmosphere in the past but it's young
hot star stripped it away leaving only a
rocky core behind
when its star Stripped Away its original
atmosphere some of the gases were
absorbed into the planet's mantle and
now through this planet's volcanism
they're released back GJ 1132b could
have become a potentially habitable
world but it's 26 times closer to its
star than Mercury is to the Sun
no chances for life on this super Earth
but life might be possible on these
slightly larger super Earths
scientists have found many of these
worlds orbiting In Their sun-like Stars
habitable zones
and that's good news now we'd have to go
and explore more of these planets up
close to find out what their atmospheres
are like this one seems intriguing
kepler-452b is 1.6 times the size of
Earth and it's about 6 billion years old
Earth is a youngster compared to this
world our planet is only four and a half
billion years old
okay now I know this is your favorite
exoplanet
Kepler-22b
and I like it too
this super Earth might be covered in a
super ocean
it sits comfortably in its star's
habitable zone and has a huge potential
for Life the only problem is that it's
big
Kepler-22b is 2.4 times larger than
Earth and about nine times more massive
if Kepler-22b was the size of Earth it
would have an average surface
temperature of about 16 degrees Celsius
but because it's a lot bigger than Earth
it could be a rocky planet a water world
or even a gaseous Planet like Neptune
and speaking of geisha's planets at this
size exoplanets stop being super Earths
and become gas giants
more than half of all exoplanets we've
discovered are either neptune-like ice
Giants or gas giants like Jupiter
and many of them orbit a little too
close to their host stars and they pay a
high price for that proximity
for one they're incredibly hot and
sometimes their host star rips their
atmosphere away
kind of like what GJ 1132b went through
but among them there are some cold
planets too
this is Kepler 16b it's not quite as
large as Jupiter but the cool thing
about it is that it orbits not one but
two stars only you wouldn't be able to
see those stars because you wouldn't be
able to stand on its surface you see
Kepler 16b is a Saturn sized gas giant
it might have some rocky elements inside
it but it's two host stars are much
cooler than our sun making Kepler 16b a
frigid lifeless world
speaking of lifeless worlds well that
might be what Earth becomes if we don't
work to stop climate change you've seen
the hundreds of wildfires spreading
across Canada well this is due to
climate change making the world hotter
and drier this toxic air made its way to
New York Toronto Detroit and Chicago
resulting in some of the worst air
quality in the world
California is trying to prevent
wildfires by purposefully burning
thousands of Acres a year this is in
order to reduce vegetation that could
fuel a catastrophic wildfire and this is
just one example of what we need to do
to help with climate change check to see
what your local and federal governments
are doing to help because we only have
one Earth and we don't want it to turn
into one of these uninhabitable
exoplanets
okay now on to the worlds that are
bigger than Jupiter this delicious
exoplanet has the density of a
marshmallow
toi 3757b is slightly larger than
Jupiter but it's not nearly as massive
but there are always bigger and badder
planets out there like Kepler's 7 being
this one is interesting Kepler 7B is
larger than Jupiter but it has half of
Jupiter's mass this means the planet is
like a super light Cloud a scorching hot
super light cloud
kepler-7b is a hot Jupiter planet it's
12 times hotter than the king of the
solar system
still kepler-7b is not the hottest or
the weirdest of the exoplanets
some of these gas giants are so
unimaginably hot that they tear
molecules apart
yeah and some planets are just doomed
1400 light years away from Earth a star
slightly bigger and hotter than our sun
is devouring its planet
this planet is called wasp 12b it's
almost double the size of Jupiter but
it's not going to last very long as far
as planetary lives go wasp 12b is so
close to its star that it takes just
over one Earth day to complete its orbit
its own star is actually eating the
planet's atmosphere making it stretch
into the shape of this egg 10 million
years from now wasp 12b will be gone
and some exoplanets are unimaginably
huge
the biggest one of them is almost seven
times larger than Jupiter
hd100546b isn't just seven times larger
than Jupiter it's also 750 times more
massive
HD orbits its star 10 times further away
than Jupiter orbits the sun that's
pretty far and it makes scientists
wonder how this gigantic exoplanet
formed so far away from its star
there's no doubt that some exoplanets
out there look promising for finding
life
we've found quite a lot of them orbiting
in the habitable zone of Their Stars
in fact some of these worlds might even
be better for life than Earth
but that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]